[Music]
my name is tintin zhou and i'm a
neuroscientist at the mcgovern institute
at mit
imagine for a second that you're a mouse
and you really like to eat a piece of
cheese but in order to get the cheese
you must remember the color of this
light you can't forget it even after
light turns off right now your most
brain is holding this important
information in an area called the
prefrontal cortex and when you have to
remember which light you saw earlier
you'll probably guess correctly this is
called working memory the mice in my lab
have difficulty with working memory they
have schizophrenia a serious brain
disorder that affects the ability to
think clearly they can now remember
information for more than a few seconds
because they have mistakes in their dna
and their prefrontal cortex doesn't
connect properly to other parts of the
brain i'm studying how we can fix the
genes and the abnormal brain connections
associated with schizophrenia so that
all mice and people can live a rewarding
life